it's been about eight months since i got
my 2019 mac pro which retails at a
massive
fifteen thousand dollars and it's been
doing a killer job editing videos in
pure silence
thanks to the excellent cooling system
but now that i've spent a few weeks with
apple's new 2025k imac it performs
so well that i started wondering if i
even need it anymore
in fact we are building a new home and i
need as much cash as possible
so if this 3500 imac can get close to
the performance of my mac pro for the
tasks that i do
daily then i'm definitely going to sell
it in pocket about 10 grand
which will be perfect for a nice home
theater setup we'll be looking at a wide
variety of uses such as logic pro xcode
photo editing with photoshop and
lightroom video editing
gaming and much more i'll tell you up
front that these tests were really
eye-opening both in favor of the mac pro
and against it
and revealed a few things that i've
never known before which are going to
change the way that i'll recommend
computers forever
and that's not clickbait and i also
highly recommend
buying an ultrasoft premium max tech
shirt
or with that one of these soft
comfortable masks
if you want to support the channel and
have something that's super
comfortable first here are the full
specs of each mac
the mac pro has two extra cores but they
are an older design and run slower than
the new imacs
but will present a few surprises my mac
pro has the vega 2 graphics with 32
gigabytes of video memory compared to
the 5700 xt
with 16 gigabytes in the imac you can
also get a w5700x in the mac pro
for a fair bit less than my mega 2 and
it's a newer design
but has less raw power and half of the
memory that also runs quite a bit slower
we also have a huge difference in ram 64
gigabytes compared to 192
which i'll show you why it really
doesn't matter
now lastly my mac pro has a 2 000
afterburner card which accelerates
prores and prores raw the mac pro comes
in at about 15 grand
but i bought the ram myself bringing it
down to 13 000
which is still almost four times the
cost of the imac
which was 3540 if you buy the ram
yourself and follow our ram install
guide
which you absolutely should do i'll link
it down below along with that the 5k
imac comes with a gorgeous 5k display
that costs 1300
to add to the mac pro now there's more
to the story such as
ports cooling upgradability and more but
let's
save that for later and jump right into
performance starting off with a good old
geekbench that tests a wide variety of
tasks the imac
win in single core due to its faster
frequency but in multi-core the pro
scores closer to 30 percent
higher now putting a constant 100 cpu
load on all of the cores and cinebench
r20 which is a 3d rendering benchmark
the i9 imac shockingly beats out the mac
pro
by just over a hundred points even
though it does have two less cores
looking deeper the results actually make
sense because the mac pro runs at 3.6
gigahertz under full load
and the imac runs at 4 gigahertz which
is overall faster
and it actually uses about 150 watts to
achieve the faster speed
instead of 170 watts so it's more
efficient but with that
it also runs much hotter and louder
because of the small chassis instead of
being completely silent
as for graphics geekbench's metal
graphics test resulted in the mac pro
scoring just over 65 higher in raw
graphics performance
which is a big difference as it should
be for a graphics card that costs
almost as much as the whole imac but
hold on because
real world performance will be
interesting looking at another graphics
test this time gaming with unigine
heaven
here instead of a 65 difference the mac
pros vega 2
is only 18 faster which is a huge
difference compared to before
that's because the latest amd rda
graphics have lots of improvements
outside of raw graphics power
they're great for gaming and a few other
things as you'll notice
the mac pro is the fastest mac for
gaming it can even handle
6k gaming but the 5k imac is almost as
good
while being a fraction of the price
graphics are also great for 3d rendering
which we use
blender to test here and the difference
was even smaller at about seven percent
only being about one minute faster to
render the bmw and classroom scenes
which is very interesting let's get into
some more common uses like photo editing
using lightroom both are extremely
smooth and fast while editing
to be honest i couldn't notice any
difference
i exported 542mbps edited raw images
which maxes out the cpu so i expect the
results to be close
but what i saw was shocking the mac pro
was practically twice
as fast these results made no sense
since cinebench was
actually faster on the imac so i
searched through
everything to find a bottleneck and
surprisingly it wasn't the ram
it wasn't the ssd and after hours of
testing and researching i figured out
that the reason the mac pro is so much
faster
is its six-channel memory instead of
dual channel
the base imac pro is slower in every way
than the 5k imac and it has half the ram
yet it was actually somewhat in between
the mac pro and the imac in terms of
performance
and that uses 4 channel memory which is
also
right there in the middle onto photoshop
once again i couldn't tell
a single difference when doing my normal
work but we ran the puget bench
photoshop mix benchmark and the mac pro
smoked the 5k
imac i'm betting it's once again because
of the 6 channel memory instead of dual
channel with that said
they trade blows in certain tasks so
pause this video to see the detailed
breakdowns
before some shockers in logic pro and
xcode let's touch on something that we
do
on the daily and that's video editing
i'll be doing a detailed review
including premiere pro and davinci
resolve tests in a dedicated video on my
filmmaking channel
which i'll link down below but here i
will focus on final cut
there's certain things that this 5700 is
just so much
faster at the same thing goes for
stabilizing 4k
hevc footage where the imac was 65
faster i exported two five minute sample
projects with multiple effects
the first being common 4k h.264 and the
second being h.265
and in both cases the mac pro was faster
i then exported one of our youtube
videos which is roughly 12 minutes long
and it has a ton of graphs and effects
and the gap actually closed up here when
your gpu
has to do all of these effects and
animations
the newer 5700 is just more efficient by
the way all of these numbers are using
the latest version of final cut which
has changed some of the results from our
previous videos
getting into tougher tests like canon
raw the mac pro is still super fast for
this
taking just 5 minutes but the imac isn't
too far behind
as for editing smoothness the mac pro
can handle 4k60 raw with effects
perfectly with some more overhead for
extra effects where the imac can barely
handle 4k60 with the lut at full
resolution
but that is still enough for most c200
editors who usually work in a 24 or 30
fps timeline
moving on to red raw using the new metal
decoding the mac pro can play back this
really compressed ak
almost perfectly in an ak timeline while
the imac is just a few frames per second
behind
and both are limited by graphics not the
processors
rendering the projects i was shocked to
see that the mac pro was actually slower
at exporting my 4.5k redraw test
by just a few seconds and for the 8k
project
exporting out to 4k the imac was
actually 22
faster which is crazy now if you had the
cheaper w5700
x in your mac pro it would match up to
the imac here but would be slightly less
smooth when you're actually doing
editing compared to the vega the new
canon r5 and r6 are very popular but
their 422 footage is tough to edit
so many people are going to be
transcoding now the mac pro can convert
30 minutes of 4k
10 bit in about 30 minutes while the
imac takes 37.
surprisingly when editing in the
timeline the imac
is actually smoother with that exporting
a 5 minute project is
actually more than a minute faster using
the imac compared to the mac pro
it's another thing that i didn't expect
and that's because the cpu can run
faster at up to five gigahertz
now my mac pro does have something that
the imac will never
get and that is the two thousand dollar
afterburner card that decodes prores and
prores raw
so the cpu doesn't have to do it it's
important to note that it won't help
transcoding
since it can't encode prores but in
cases when you're going from one flavor
of prores to another like this 4k pro vs
raw project
there is a noticeable speed difference
since the cpu can focus solely on
encoding
the results are similar testing ak
prores raw to ak prores where the
afterburner equipped pro
is significantly faster but if you don't
dish out two grand for this extra card
the 10 core imac is just as fast as the
12 core mac pro
as far as playback the imac can handle
one stream of 8k
prores raw in an 8k project perfectly
smooth
exactly like the mac pro without
afterburner but neither can do
more than that with the afterburner my
mac pro can do four streams of 8k
or a single stream of 16k pro res ra
which is something that this imac will
never do so if you'll need to have an
afterburner or the ability to say by a
28 core
or have four graphics card you'll only
be able to do that
in a mac pro overall for the vast
majority of people the 5k imac with the
5700 xt
is rounding up to be an amazing bargain
for video editing
in some cases it's actually faster than
my mac pro and when it's slower
the difference isn't dramatic now what
about logic pro
x and also xcode well the results are
going to surprise you
the imac could handle 125 tracks before
shutting down on our logic benchmark
which is really respectable
and enough for most people and i
expected the mac pro to be similar
but it handled up to 227 tracks
once again probably because of memory
bandwidth the results were similar in
our custom
xcode benchmark where the mac pro was
almost twice as fast
even though the test maxed out the cpu
on both now
unlike logic though the imac pro was
slower than the imac for xcode
so i can't say it's a memory bandwidth
limitation but the mac pro
sure is fast for compiling code overall
as far as performance
this i9 5700xt imac is more than enough
for most people
even most professionals and it's much
faster than just a few years ago
massive difference with that said the
mac pro does excel if you're pushing it
to the absolute extremes and beyond
and for compiling code and exporting
photos it is much quicker
and for some of the people out there
that might be doing a ton of that
constantly on the daily it might be
worth spending three to five times as
much
depending on the configuration and your
monitor's price
along with that the mac pro is almost
dead
silent where the imac will sound like a
hair dryer and many of these rendering
tests
which does get annoying but if most of
your time is spent
editing photos and editing the video and
not constantly rendering it
then it stays mostly quiet the mac pro
also has
eight thunderbolt ports up to 12
actually depending on your graphics
instead of having two
and it has dual 10 gigabit ethernet
instead of one 10 gig ethernet
and of course it's expandable in the
future so if you're going to keep your
machine for many years that is a
definite plus
on the flip side imacs hold their value
so well
that it might actually be cheaper to
upgrade every few years to the latest
and greatest
instead of holding on to a mac pro for
say 10 years
where the value will go from 15 000 down
to just a few
i just sold my 2017 imac and it cost me
1200
to own it for three years so you could
do the math yourself there
after all of that testing the imac does
indeed get very close to the mac pro
in the daily professional tasks that i
do and it is
actually faster for editing my canon r5
footage
so with that said the mac pro is going
to be put up for sale
so if you're interested in getting a
great deal
on a mac pro let me know down in the
comment section below
if you guys want to see the full final
review of the 2020
5k imac make sure you guys click that
subscribe button up above
and check out one of these ultra premium
soft shirts down below in the merch
shelf
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video